What is sunnah? What does it mean? And
how many types of sunnah are there?
Alhamdulillah.
The word sunnah literally means the way
or the custom. And the sunnah of the
prophet means the way of the prophet or
the prophet's tradition. The word sunnah
it indicates and means
the sayings the deeds and the approval
of the prophet in the span of 23 years
during his prophethood. It means what
the prophet said, what the prophet did
and what the prophet approved in the
span of 23 years during his prophethood.
And the sunnah of the prophet can be
divided into three types.
The first is
suni
that means the sayings of the prophet.
The second is
fali that means
the actions of the prophet and the third
is sun
which means the approval of the prophet.
So basically these three types of sunnah
are there in three different categories.